right Democratic - that's what they do
ah Barack we miss you no don't
ah he was a very unsuccessful American
president and his foreign policy was a
catastrophe not successful I think it
was really successful and really
brilliant and gave me hope for their
better world didn't even managed to
close Guantanamo Bay which he promised
to do made a complete pig's ear of Syria
and of the whole Arab Spring I'm not
saying we did it brilliantly but America
lost global leadership in the Middle
East and has allowed Putin to take over
in terms of policy we should all be too
blind for that I'd still rather have
Barack Obama any single day of the week
I wouldn't let Trump look after my
children let alone my country I
certainly wouldn't lay wouldn't let him
near any of my family the American
people of Asia he has two Trump and he's
got a Democratic mandate and I respect
Democratic mandates
he has the right to be there he has
annoyed to be there and I have the right
to say they is in terrible hoodude to
the rest of the world it's in the
British national interest that we get on
with the United States at what cost
this is Trump's gift appear to cause
some confusion and love Michelle Obama
the cameras and I think people should
stop being horrible about Trump's wife I
think that I've heard you know lots and
lots of time spent slugging her off and
I think it's totally and that's that
well we can have a moment of agreement
yeah
because I think mrs. trauma she has an
amazing representation of the American
dream yeah that she escapes from very
working-class beginning she escapes from
Soviet bloc living in a concrete Adri
block in the Soviet Union and becomes
the First Lady of the United States I
think that's so remarkable
yeah but the American Dream has never
quite delivered anyone to be the top of
America other than to be married to the
top of America mrs. Clinton would have
been in exactly the same position
well if she's got the presidency only
because she was married mr. Clinton oh
my god she was a politician within her
own right she was a good she was a
lawyer she was small she 30 well
qualified complete to this shows that
she was complete Cape Taylor and the
American people in their wisdom rejected
her god bless them special outrageous
today we are not merely transferring
power I is a day that administration to
another or from one party to another but
we are transferring power from
Washington DC and giving it back to you
the people what a load of rubbish
you have got Wall Street men in your
team you don't give a toss about the
American people at all and the idea that
he is anti-establishment is like saying
that I'm from the establishment and
you're not but you are now you see the
truth is you're part of the Metropolitan
liberal elite with my liberal tears all
right
absolutely and I'm not and and I'm very
pleased not to be part of the liberal
elite most disagreeable could argue that
I was from the establishment and well
you work all the new establishment you
see met my type of old-fashioned
fuddy-duddy establishment long since
passed into history where you are the
you are the new establishment from this
day forward it's going to be only
America first sounds like he's really
great for Britain doesn't it after the
pageantry the protest but mostly
actually looks like there's aren't they
had in November when tram one you can
understand why women might be a little
bit challenged he is a an open sexual
predator
he has admitted to seeking to sexually
assault women that is that is not OK in
my opinion for the leader of any country
and I can understand exactly why the
women in America and the women around
the world felt that they needed to stand
in solidarity with each other for our
rights a very large number of women
voted for him absolutely and he's there
has got the support of the American
people I in a ditch for those women to
have their right to vote to say I don't
perfectly that's what they do but and I
mean it's easy to understand why women
feel challenged by it I think Donald
Trump on his best heart can't cope do
you think he would have grabbed the hand
of a male politician well I'm not very
touchy-feely so I I'm Jacob we could hug
it out I'd have been able to put bit but
I'd if he had solid ground on my hand I
just don't believe I would ever have
done that and I think he did it to sort
of overpower her I didn't that's right
all he really is scared of slaves I
think it elegantly symbolized the
special relationship being alive and
well I don't suppose he'll hold mrs
merkel's hand well unless he's very
brave Americans are more touchy-feely
than we are they don't
yeah like Europe because of all the
kissing no quiet no ransom I don't know
but Americans are much more likely to
grab you by the arm and things like that
the British are no deal for Britain is
better than a bad deal for Britain's
subsea right that's not absolutely not
surprised not only righted a bad deal is
a bad deal a bad deal is worse than No
Deal or No Deal
No Deal what does that no deal means
with nothing to you know well don't have
a WTO terms be fine because absolutely
to the time the street where I live
won't be foul it'll be absolutely fine
we will be able to trade with a whole
the rest the world will set out in
terraced rather countries we could make
the cost of food considerably lower if
we took tariffs off the rest of the
world the cost of clothing considerably
lower the very big savings to have being
assets if it gets sold into your at 40%
of will make you a lot of what they
produce was still bit on top of that
still be doesn't matter lot of what
exported will still be needed because
it's part of the integrated
manufacturing process they made their
choice they want to leave the EU that's
right that's the to ask themselves as
they go through the lobbies tonight is
do they trust the people quite right and
I trust the people my dad always said
King Clarke is a Tory you've allowed to
load apparently you follow the rabbit
down the hole and you emerge in a
Wonderland where suddenly countries
throughout the world are queuing up to
give us trading advantages a lot to me
asleep around the corner the mess in
Birmingham I like lots of toys
I find it relatively easy sorry the
screams my father I mean my dad used to
say this long before you were in part of
my Jacob I'm sure he would reassess his
list of Tories you're allowed to like no
but thank you mr. speaker all Mr
Miliband always loses elections and he
doesn't like it we do not want to give
the sense that people having voted for
breakfast they felt they've been ignored
are being ignored once again I think
here's one of the ablest politicians in
the country he's everywhere I look every
turn on a corner and Alec Simon is there
lurking Alice only took herself into the
hall very able man
Prime Minister is taking virtually all
the Tory party half the Labour Party and
the entire country into the hall you're
obviously gonna be chuffed about 2017
you think it's going pretty good
you've got Trump in America brexit in
the UK Mike returns the UK and for
Britain this year's got off to a
fantastic start that breaks it is going
ahead extremely smoothly so far we're in
a strong position the economy's held up
all the gloomy stories have failed to
materialize 2017 looks like this can be
a year of legend and song quite a lot of
people feel like it's bit of it claim
you know there well some of the 48% of
people in very few very very really
because I get a lot of them emailing me
do you not get that
well that's probably because you're very
good as an agony are to take over
thinking 2017 so far feels as if all the
bad stuff has happened in one in one
fell swoop the whole you know Trump has
been the president for like 15 minutes
and it's like executive order after
executive order doing absolutely but
your most traffic things in the UK I
don't feel as positive as you I feel
braced for the potential and can only
hope that it's going to be okay and I
will keep hold of that hope but at the
moment hope is all I have well there's
always hope it was the last thing to
come out of Pandora's box
what hate was hope hope came limping out
after
all the Furies and disasters had left my
hope has taken is the last thing to come
out of the box definitely there's so
much to hope about it is a wonderful
time pronto I have eternally hope you
should be alright to be
[Music]